hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
it's a because I speak for you you speak
for me go for it dude speak in my voice
[Laughter]
Amy have you ever seen the channel
corridor crew I cannot say that I have
Greg although well these guys are
awesome they're VFX artists they have a
bunch of great segments and I think you
will love I'm here for it people have
asked us to check out this video called
stuntmen react to bad and great
Hollywood stunts number three doesn't
matter it's number three
you know what I want to show you this
one yeah this is just one of their
segments okay but they got like a bunch
of different stuff and these guys are
fantastic they're one of my favorites
you look pipe this up to the right
amount and I am ready to watch that car
wasn't there also that kind of middle is
a stuntman no okay
hello everyone we are back with another
stuntman to react
we're gonna break down some of the
coolest and perhaps not so cool stunt
scenes from your favorite films let's do
it alright rated loved this movie you
should watch it love it I don't need you
trying to fight with machete would be
like the worst experience the reaction
do you know he's like really weaving in
and out of everybody I mean that was
great like he hits them with machete
even though he's got the best on so it
wasn't really
Wow how do how do not just murder a man
for the sake of our generate their
different theories I think it's dummy
ones like a dude they're like Ronin yeah
it does well if you see the his feet at
the end they don't completely round so
they stop Matt or something right it's
for sure green screen and them added in
later can use a give it back oh that's
so cool that's so cool they know that I
I think the rains great something that
like a lot of stuff man don't love about
it is whenever they need beaks in
between the beats they go like this with
their hands a bit of that might work
they're constantly like on the move in
between beats there's way people falling
down like that are constantly trying not
to have egg on the face against them
hands it's gonna fill in the gaps with
doing something I'll just slip and fall
and then stand back up and try to be on
the same timing with a third Batman
movie him and Catwoman are fighting all
the other goons people were taking
reactions when they're hit by nothing
[Laughter]
Nolan guys know it and if they do have
playback he just like kind of watches
the monitor Oh interesting
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh I do know that I drove out a car you
know I'm supposed to do 25 months now
her but the guy who's driving is like
he's like will go about 20 25 but the
thing is is that when you're you're
doing some sort of cardiac when you get
to the like main part you kind of like
limine on it so you're going 28 an
effects guy blows the windshield right
and you know what's gonna happen but you
don't realize how loud it's gonna be and
how insane it is when you're in there
sure I'm in the back seat and glass
starts blowing all over my face see the
point that I'm supposed to go with the
door open and dive out right that was
amazing great moving on everybody starts
packing up their stuff I'm seeing in the
corner I've knocked a window myself one
[Music]
and I can't save me because I can't
breathe oh yeah I just knew I didn't
want to screw it up like they're blowing
everything up and yeah I think the next
day I might name all the cool in my body
John wick chapter to see just on the
first opening only in a movie directed
by a stuntman would anybody be like yeah
we're gonna use the car this guy
literally had to initiate a slide where
he hits the ramp so that then when he
launches through the air he's going
sideways and then had to kind of gather
it up Reeves he did a lot of this
driving stuff himself like you get a lot
of great shots of him in there sliding
the car you know interacting with the
camera which is I mean just action kick
cars where they get something like a
Lamborghini that would be way too
expensive to crash and they remake the
body own stuff that isn't carbon-fiber
that may look like it and they're also
putting an engine in it that could be
still work and drive they can crash it
without the cost Oh interesting
well he also slid into that position
looks like he's closed the back tire I
think you still probably could have
pulled it off with the limit line so
that the back wheels couldn't possibly
touch I got you they certainly did that
with a stunt man a couple of times
they're like look it's gonna land here
and Kiana's yes he knows he's gonna get
hit so he takes his uh one of his feet
and kind of gets up to get touched yeah
so he knows good leg and then once
you're weak kind of hits it it takes
your other leg up watch it's not right
spits mom I feel like the style so it's
like really interesting really brutal
you know more realistic it is see how
he's yanking him with this with this
jacket I mean that is what you would
actually do and to try to get somebody
off balance or control their
or their body or where you wanted to go
although it doesn't always look as sexy
is like something in the raid whether
they're popping constantly Agent Smith
the subway fight he goes flying back and
he hits like a subway like ticket taking
thing yeah you know smashes through it
well if you watch it he doesn't break it
and just head just get slammed like this
he took some gnarly hits in the matrix
Chad's been amazing with these films and
I think that you get some really great
stuff that most directors wouldn't be
able to pull off do you do a lot of car
stuff I've definitely done a decent
amount of driving I know some of the
guys do stuff and those guys are really
true car guys you know they can
literally slide it and stop on a dime
it's unbeliev I feel like The Fast and
Furious franchise like start out with
all good intentions it was pretty cool
they were doing something different with
the stretch reality just ya know in the
Hot Wheels now it's like a video game
yeah
can you look up the the Fast and Furious
where they're dragging the stage yeah
what that's a real that's why it looks
really good what they did is I know the
guys that did this and that vault that
they're dragging through the string is a
car but what I did is I took a bow and I
cut the entire middle half out of it
from the back of the front wheels to the
front of the back wheels we took that
out and we welded it back together so
all it has is an engine front wheels and
back wheels and a seat and that's
essentially it
whoa CGI
no creative sliding oh my gosh like like
drifting this car with the bankfull
around it are you kidding yeah cuz those
wires and everything are all there so he
is tearing up with these guys and
driving this thing that's so scary
driving it what a great idea like if you
were like I want to drag this this bolt
through the street like would you have
thought to have a human in thank you for
adding is a lot of fun to break this
stuff down with you guys now if you
don't have questions about that yeah
absolutely I try to answer everybody at
leader or not I'm not very famous just
your body's very famous things crazy
what you guys watch it leave a comment
down below if he wants to react to any
future you can't wait to read Wow
dude I'm impressed dude that's nuts
I just looks like so much fun and
terrifying I've always felt like some
men don't get enough credit I don't know
if they still do this stuntman Awards I
remember when I was younger I saw live
broadcast I think I like ABC when I was
younger I've heard a couple of different
discussions like stuntmen I've done a
couple of stumble in my life and some
stunt men really like the mystique the
fact that they don't get credit because
it's the whole point of a stunt man is
you're supposed to fill in for these
actors and make it look like that the
actors are doing it so when you still
have your anonymity when you walk oh
yeah exactly so they really think it's
cool that they're not as well
acknowledged at the same time I'm like
really you guys risk your freaking lives
to amusant this thing you know they get
paid for it and all but yeah they have
to work so hard they literally are
putting their lives on the line just for
our own entertainment and when they get
injured like that's some time off of
work that they can't be working it's got
to be a crazy I mean a fashion a lot of
stuntmen die a lot of stuff
get hospitalized I mean for this guy to
be like it or not I'm not famous I'm
like well I believe you're not famous it
was just funny to me that the guy on the
left is the one that has like the risk
you're not the stupid okay we must I got
carpal tunnel from all the VFX typing
these guys just like some great VFX
breakdowns and stuff so I think it's
really cool they got this segment going
start where you can really break it down
seeing things that I just don't ever
pick up on yeah I would have no idea of
how they do that like with the raid
where they pull that guy at he slams in
her neck on the broken door spot of the
idea of like they green-screen that and
that's probably a dummy I would have
never thought that I was like man he's
something are crazy how that's that man
pull that off there's nuts with that
attention to detail where he's like look
at his feet you could see the feet in
the way it bounces that is probably on a
mat it's not hitting the ground that's a
dummy like you makes you makes me kind
of want to look out for these things
when I watch these action movies now
it's like these little bonus puzzles
that you get to solve how do they do
that it's really impressive or when they
do like these crazy-ass thing I remember
there was like Bond movie called
Tomorrow Never Dies where bond is remote
controlling a vehicle okay and what they
did was they had to put a stuntman
driver in the driver seat but he's like
in the seat so you can't see him yeah
like he's in
so I remember that fact slightly wrong
but that whole thing would fast five
carrying that the safer route yeah every
time I'm seeing that movie I just assume
those CGI I had no idea that was Pratt
dome like that's one great-looking CGI
it looks like they're really dragon yeah
nuts they built this whole machinery
just to pull off this cool finale I'm so
much appreciation for people that are
gonna take the time to do that cuz it's
I mean I don't know what's faster if you
do it CG I mean at this point I mean
it's faster it's cheaper yeah look as
good no and it's just not as believable
because I'm always thought that finale
was like ridiculous but it was always so
cool at the same time yeah and now that
I know they really did that whoa really
this is even cooler points just shot
through the roof yeah I feel like I can
watch this guy talk about John wick
forever I only said about stun porn that
was I'm only seeing the first one I
noticed to be true yeah I mean that the
directors of them were stuntmen and now
they've gone on to have flourishing
careers as directors makes sense why the
action they're able to capture it's so
real yeah it's all within camera it's
not reliant on CGI that's shot of the
car doing the spin and the camera pans
at the same time shops like that I get
so used to seeing stuff like that yeah
that I take it for granted I don't
realize that all like oh it's that's
probably like a really hard stunt to get
down yeah my heart shot and their timing
on that too it's just like but I watch
it in the moment and I'm like cool you
know it's cool yeah but then when I
think about if I was on set that day and
that's what you're doing for this five
seconds five seconds of a shot good
editing if it's done well you don't
notice it so exactly the same way with
these stunts like if they all go
according to plan you don't really
notice how much effort went into it the
things that some people just write off
as just entertainment and not art I'm
like nah there's art to the
entertainment and when you watch
something like this I find my
appreciation is just so enhanced to me
it's like beautiful what they do there
is a dancers artist I like I love that
breakdown they were talking about with
fights is I'm a big fan of fight scenes
and guys because there's the dead space
is that funny I didn't realize
was a problem with film because he said
Nolan shoots with film so he doesn't
have playback oh yeah and I make sense
now maybe they did want to insert
something in there later I feel like
I've heard about that before where that
guy just falls over because they they
must have wanted to imagine that guy's
like okay I'm really gonna stand out in
this scene here I'm gonna react or
something in there because nothing that
is somebody making the most of their
time that's like an extra who's really
trying to stand yeah I want to be
upgraded to an under-five line please so
funny the thing is a lot of fight scenes
we were fighting multiple people there
is that thing where people are just
standing yeah and they're waiting to be
hit like they're doing they're doing
something where they like how do we fill
in the gap there same with the rate of
how they're doing this to fill in the
gap instead of just standing around cuz
I noticed that in almost every fight
scene with a group of people there's
usually one or two people I see who are
just waiting yeah well I've studied
fight scenes since I was a little kid
because I grew up on like Jackie Chan
Jet Li I like martial arts I do martial
arts when I was younger so I knew a lot
of fight choreographers or are any
people who are at least a spot I didn't
know like professionals but I need a lot
people who are aspiring to the point
where I was able to study it and notice
it I do notice any group fights and I'm
like that guys are standing waiting a
lot of times it's like someone gets hit
and they're like oh my turn
like this waiting go thing and it's it
does pull me out of the moment yeah this
is great I think or a crew is an amazing
channel one of those films study
channels especially if you want to be a
director to know more work with these
things I feel like these guys are one of
the best go to channels well now I'm a
viewer now cuz I was not aware of it I'm
into it so thank you I know you're in
the film so I was like I'm gonna
introduce Amy do these guys cool thanks
for being here and plus these guys are
funny awesome
so I mean as a single lady I can't
appreciate inviter encore to go flirt
with you guys in person yeah I must do
the first youtuber to forget to say
subscribe to the real
subscribe to corner crew click that
notification bell and follow Amy castle
it's Amy castle back to the video I
would like to give a page from the day
shout out to a man named Andrew
Nickerson this guy's from Washington and
apparently it was his birthday on July
21st feeling the curtain are we he just
turned 64 years old happy birthday you
young sprightly managed 34 yeah he
turned 34 he has some big goals in life
he wants to get his own house by next
year he wants to settle down Amy I think
he's your guy just matchmaking this into
his name Andrew Nickerson Amy Nickerson
Double A MN CEO who doesn't I mean I
wasn't gonna go there but you did so now
that's when we are cursing Dicker's yeah
I feel like there's a great joke here
and I'm just not finding I'm really
looking where we're trying to find it
happy birthday happy birthday happy
birthday to you
have a good day